I love how open you are about mental
health because I have similar issues and
I have suffered from depression Kelly
Clarkson opens up to Demi Lovato about
her struggle with depression I think a
lot of people especially in the creative
world or just from childhood you've been
kind of trained to like just keep going
and you can handle it and especially as
a woman it's like don't let him see you
sweat the talk show host praised Emmy
for being so open with her fans on
Thursdays the Kelly Clarkson show I just
love that you're open about that because
not everybody's as vulnerable at being
like that and I think it's helpful for
your fans and the love is mutual
I'm excited the 27 year old singer
opened up about how Kelly's transparency
helped her at the start of her own
career you were like the first Idol that
I ever had and so sweet I wouldn't be
the artist or even the person that I am
with being so outspoken and vulnerable
and fearless if I hadn't had you to look
up to so I think usually that'd be nice
yes I just like I looked at you as my
idol growing up um are Kelly and Demi
Hollywood's newest besties absolutely
I'm 10 out of 10 here for it you are
fearless and courageous and real as you
know and you and I love that about you
and I've always just thought to myself
like when I was young I always talked to
myself if I ever make it I want to be
like her because she's real and she's
genuine all the feels thank you and
Kelly was feeling the feels too but the
38 year old also admitted that her life
isn't always as easy as it might seem it
takes work like it's like that's the
thing I think everybody looks at us is
like like even when you overcome
something they're like okay so she's
already overcome they're like no no
that's a daily effort and like trying to
be positive that's a daily effort and
and that's not like a given like you
just over it and you went to some
magical therapy session and it's over I
think that's a daily thing that you work
at earlier this month
Kelly filed for divorce from her husband
Brandon Blackstock after more than six
years of marriage the pair share five
year old daughter River and
four-year-old son Remy let it go live
your life and do what you feel is right
earlier this month
a source told ET the two decided to call
it quits after they realized the
relationship hadn't been working for a
while
honestly um I have been an emotional
roller coaster Kelley recently opened up
about her abandonment issues stemming
from her childhood during a chat with a
British web series glamour unfiltered I
don't think you get rid of them you know
I have people in my life that suffer
from addiction to certain things and and
that doesn't go away it's always there
it's just navigating your life around
that existence in your life so you don't
ever like one day wake up and are like
okay I'm totally cool with the fact that
I have major Brannen issues cuz there's
you know horrible things happens out of
all of that you've got to recognize at
some point though that it's made you who
you are
[Music]